welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
aka your friendly neighborhood spoiler
man in this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about the
big bad of the mcu
that is thanos since his introduction in
the avengers
the characters become one of the most
fascinating villains ever put to film
and throughout this video we'll be going
over everything you need to know about
him
there will be some spoilers here so if
you aren't fully up to speed with the
infinity saga then i hope you get dusted
because we're gonna be spoiling
everything we're still here
thanks for sticking around now let's get
into our breakdown of thanos
okay so thanos originally started as an
idea in jim starling's mind
all the way back when he was studying
psychology in college
along with drax the destroyer stalling
thought of the pair of comic book
characters
as entities that both dealt with anger
issues and
after going to marvel he was asked to
pen an issue of iron man
stalin didn't believe that his career
would last longer than a couple of weeks
and thus he threw his all into this
entry and used it as an opportunity to
drop them in
he pitched the idea of thanos to marvel
and though they liked him
they had some notes and pointers for the
up-and-coming comic book creator
dallas was originally a relatively
normal sized character
that initially appeared on the same
level as the man but this changed over
time
stalin has gone back and forth over this
saying that his original idea was to
have him
more in line with a villain like metron
but that marvel talked him into taking
thanos in a new direction
admiring what jack kirby had done with
the new gods the heads at marvel stated
that
if they were going to steal one of them
then they might as well rip off the best
and thus thanos ended up being more in
line with darkseid than anyone else
first appearing in the invincible iron
man 55
all the way back in 1973 he quickly
became a foe for the metal man
the original captain marvel avengers and
silver surfer
when infinity war was about to be
released marvel reprinted pretty much
all of his appearances and even gave a
helpful reading list of what to check
out
i've actually read through the majority
of these for my website and though some
of them
are hit and miss there are some genuine
classics in there
such as the silver surfer appearances
and of course infinity gauntlet
now all of these stories kind of combine
to create the version that we've come to
know and love
depending on who you ask the marvel
cinematic universe version of the
character
was born on titan to a-laws thanos
possessed a deviant gene
which radically changed his appearance
and though he was initially ostracized
due to his brilliant mind he quickly
rose up through the ranks of the society
thanos very much wished to be both
brilliant and
deadly and thus he built his body too
quickly becoming an almost godlike
figure amongst the race
this has piqued your interest then i
definitely recommend that you check out
thanos rising as
it sort of tells his origin story in a
really well fleshed out way
that kind of falls in line more with the
source material but
in the mcu thanos loved his planet and
he was very proud of their
accomplishments
however as with most civilizations they
eventually hit a point
that ultimately led to their extinction
thanos realized that overpopulation
would completely decimate the species
and thus he suggested that half the
population be culled to ensure that the
other half could survive
the idea was thought to be far too
drastic and he was labeled as a madman
for even suggesting it
thanos was exiled from the planet and he
watched from afar as they slowly started
to succumb to his prophecy
thus thanos was the last of his race and
after learning the hard way he decided
that he wouldn't allow the rest of the
universe to fall to the same fate
using his intellect and power he quickly
built up an army and moved through space
wiping out half of the population on
planets one by one
in his eyes he was balancing the
universe and though he earned the
reputation as being a warlord
he soon gained a vast amount of devout
followers
that believed him to be the most
powerful being in the universe
amongst these were the orphans that he
collected from several of the races that
he conquered
and along with gamora and nebula he also
picked up ebony more
corvus glaib cull obsidian and proxima
midnight
who went on to form the black order
though thanos on the surface
seemingly treated his children like
soldiers when it came to gamora
he actually genuinely cared for her and
over the years he gained a lot of
respect for the character
and even became affectionate towards her
thanos used to force gamora and nebula
to fight one another
and he would then amputate a certain
aspect of the loser in order to make
them stronger
gamora never lost and thus nebula became
mentally damaged
and hateful of a sibling thanos
seemingly favored gamora above all
else and even after she started to
detest him
he still believed that she would one day
fall back in line
and he saw her as an heir together along
with the other
and chitauri forces they destroyed the
ecosystem on several planets in order to
balance them out
but it wasn't too long before thanos
realized that it would take too long for
him to complete this task in his
lifetime
thus he started to research a faster way
to end half of all life in the universe
and this is when he discovered the
infinity stones these
objects of immense power were scattered
across the known universe
and if they were collected they could
accomplish his goal
thus he made it his life's mission to
gather them
now the first stone that thanos came
across was the mine stone
and he placed this into a scepter which
could be used to control the minds of
those that were against him
he too learned of the power stone and
sent nebula and gamora to retrieve it
under korat's command nebula fell into a
trap during this
and thanos who detested failure told
gamora that she was not allowed to
rescue her under any circumstances
nebula tore off her own arm to escape
and though the orb wasn't retrieved
thanos allowed her to return
disappointed in her abilities
thanos sent gamora to find the soul
stone and though
she found a map detailing its location
she burned it
and lied to the titan saying that the
stone's location was unknown
it's at this time that danos made an
allegiance with ronan the accuser
who carried out several massacres for
the titan during one of these he made a
draxa's entire family
which formed a vendetta between the two
after the tesseract was awakened on
earth
thanos recruited loki to lead his
chittori forces
and here they would try and gain the
tesseract in exchange for handing it
over
thanos would give loki rule over the
entire planet however
the avengers fought back they managed to
beat loki
and also gain the scepter containing the
mind stone which thanos had gifted him
with for his mission
hydra commandeered this from shield and
started their research on it
whilst thor took the tesseract back to
asgard
upon being defeated by the earthlings
which had been labeled unruly wretches
thanos stood up and smiled realizing
that he'd finally found something that
would challenge him
then i started to study the avengers
most notably tony stark
who he viewed as a kindred spirit
someone that was cursed with knowledge
thanos worked away in the shadows
sending his minions out to manipulate
events in order to bring the stones
together
but he was betrayed by ronan who after
locating the power stone
decided that he would use it to get
revenge on xandar ronan murdered the
other
nebula joined him before they were both
defeated by the guardians of the galaxy
the orb was collected and given to the
nova corps which meant that thanos had
lost another stone
it's during this time that he got the
infinity gauntlet constructed
by the dwarves of nidovelir and state
that he would do the job of collecting
the stones himself
nebula snuck on board the sanctuary too
and tried to assassinate him
but was captured which does play into
infinity war
it's at this point that thanos learned
of the location of all the stones
and he set out after them he arrived on
xandar and infiltrated the nova corps hq
which is where he found the orb thanos
placed it into the infinity gauntlet
and he then made his position known
killing half of the zandarians before
heading out to get the tesseract from
the asgardians that had become refugees
on their way to earth
with the black order thanos killed half
of the population onboard the ship
whilst the other half escaped to earth
and he took the space stone from the
tesseract before
killing loki and beating hulk and thor
almost to death
here he gave his speech about how lost
turns the legs to jelly
and how destiny always catches up this
plays into the final few moments of his
life
which we'll talk about at the end of the
video but it's a very important line to
bear in mind
thanos sent his black order out to
retrieve the time and mind stone
whilst he went after the reality and
soul stone
this is where we pretty much get all of
the events of infinity war play out
with thanos collecting the stones one by
one he even
sacrificed gamora in order to get the
soul stone and he made it his mission to
track them down
no matter the cost nebula escaped during
this time
and she faced down against thanos on
titan along with the guardians and some
of the avengers
thanos bested them and almost killed
tony stark
however the titans spared his life in
exchange for the time stone
before heading to earth to collect the
mine stone here he
easily defeated those that tried to stop
him and even brought the vision back to
life using the time stone in order to
collect the gem
it's at this moment that thor threw
stonebreaker at him and though
this could have been fatal due to thor
wishing to boast
he did not go for the killing stroke and
thus thanos managed to carry out the
snap
which wiped out half of all life in the
universe at this moment
all of time froze except for thanos who
was transported to the soul world
without the wound in his chest
or the infinity gauntlet in this
seemingly endless void
he approached a young gamora who had
been waiting for him
when asked what the mission had cost he
stated everything
and you truly got the feeling that it
may have all been for nothing
thanos to me is very much an example of
why you should be careful what you wish
for
as he lost the only person that he cared
about in order to carry out something
that would
eventually be undone still he didn't
have time to mourn
and he returned to the real world mere
seconds after he'd carried out the snap
with the time stone he healed his chest
and used the space stone to escape to
his garden
which is where he watched the sun set on
what he thought was a grateful universe
the reality was completely different and
the character was far away from the
screams of pain that echoed across the
universe
as life was snuffed out for seemingly no
reason
the universe ended a phase of anger and
mourning and thanos settled on his form
living a rather simple life for three
weeks thanos
clearly started to second guess whether
what he'd done was the right thing or
not
and to avoid the temptation of bringing
those he'd sentenced to the abyss back
he destroyed the infinity stones by
using their own energies against them
this added further damage to his body
and he spent his remaining few days
severely wounded and limping around his
home it's at this point that he was
ambushed by the avengers who tracked the
character through his use of the
infinity stones
and nebula's knowledge of the garden
they cut off his arm
and then beheaded him ending the
character's life
however it wouldn't be the last time
that we saw him and after the avengers
travel back in time to get the infinity
stones
an alternate version of thanos from 2014
followed the group back through the
quantum realm
and here he sent nebula to get the iron
gauntlet in the wreckage of avengers hq
he fought iron man thaw and captain
america
beating the three and leaving most of
them severely wounded
the avengers however had managed to
reverse the snap and joined by the
heroes of the universe
the resistance were able to defeat
thanos now i love this younger version
of thanos
as we truly see the character for what
he is it's clear that
deep down he's a sadistic murderer and
after seeing that his plan
failed through knowing the future he
realizes that
rather than deciding not to do it he
must instead wipe out all life in the
universe
this is because he knew that the
survivors of the snap would always
remember what they'd lost
and focus on that instead of what they
gained which would lead to them living
in despair
thus all life had to be reduced to a
single atom
and reconstructed grateful of what they
had rather than what they didn't
thanos managed to retrieve the gauntlet
however due to the stark tech
now embedded in it tony was able to take
the stones and carry out his own snap
which wiped out all of his forces
thanos accepted his defeat with dignity
and he watched as the loss turned his
legs to jelly
he sat down became dust much like the
fate he wanted to force upon others
but will he be back well a deleted scene
for avengers endgame
revealed that like the rest of the
survivors if the snap
which will them out of existence is
reversed
then he could return on top of this we
have the what if series which is set to
feature a vocal appearance by josh
brolin
so it does look like we might be seeing
his grimace looking head
sooner rather than later but who knows
if it's gonna be for good
or just a cameo which i hope it's for
good because
i love the guy now either way that's
everything you need to know about thanos
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown of the
insane details in avengers end game that
you only notice after binge watching the
mcu
it's one of our best easter egg videos
ever so definitely check it out if you
want something else to watch after this
don't forget that every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays
and all you have to do to be with a
chance of winning the mcu infinity saga
box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on if
you want to support the channel and get
to see content like this early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat to
us on our discord server in the
description or heavy spoilers on twitter
anyway that's everything in the video
thank you for making it until the end
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you